The following
content is provided
by MIT OpenCourseWare under
a Creative Commons license.
Additional information
about our license
and MIT OpenCourseWare
in general,
is available at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Up on the web
now are lots of sections,
including this
conjugate gradients,
so today is the end of the
conjugate gradients discussion,
and it's kind of a
difficult algorithm.
It's beautiful and
slightly tricky,
but if I just see what the
point is of conjugate gradients,
we don't have to check that the
exact formulas that I've listed
here -- so that's one step
of conjugate gradients:
going from k minus 1 to k, and
we'll look at each of the five
steps in the cycle, without
patiently checking all those
formulas.
We'll just, sort of, see
how much work is involved.
But let me begin where we were
last time, which was Arnoldi.
So Arnoldi was a
Gram-Schmidt-like algorithm,
not exactly Gram-Schmidt, that
produced an orthogonal basis,
and that basis is the basis
for the Krylov subspace.
So each new basis vector
in the Krylov subspace
is found by multiplying
by another power of A,
but that's a terrible basis.
So the basis that we get from
these guys has to be improved,
orthogonalized, and
that's what Arnoldi does.
And if we look to see
what it does matrix-wise,
it turns out to be exactly
-- have that nice equation,
that we're creating a matrix
Q with the orthogonal vectors,
and a matrix H that tells
us how they were connected
to the matrix A. OK.
So that's the central equation,
and the properties of H
are important.
So we saw that the key property
was, in general, we've got --
it's full up in
that upper corner,
just the way
Gram-Schmidt would be.
But in case A is a
symmetric matrix,
then we can check that H will
be symmetric from this formula.
And the fact that
it's symmetric means
that those are zeros
up there, because we
know there are zeros down here.
We know there's
only one diagonal
below the main diagonal.
And if it's symmetric,
then there's
only one diagonal above,
and that's the great case,
the symmetric case.
So I'm going to take
two seconds just to say,
here is the best way
to find eigenvalues.
We haven't spoken one word
about computing eigenvalues,
but this is the moment
to say that word.
If I have a symmetric matrix,
eigenvalues are way, way easier
for symmetric matrices.
Linear systems are also
easier, but eigenvalues
are an order of magnitude
easier for symmetric matrices.
And here is a really good
way to find the eigenvalues
of large matrices.
I assume that you don't
want all the eigenvalues.
I mean, that is very unusual
to need many, many eigenvalues
of a big matrix.
You're looking -- probably those
high eigenvalues are not really
physically close, good
representations of the actual
eigenvalues of the
continuous problem.
So, we have continuous
and discrete
that are close for
the low eigenvalues,
because that's where
the error is smooth.
High eigenvalues
are not so reliable.
So for the low eigenvalues,
here is a good way to do them.
Do Arnoldi, and it gets named
also, now, after Lanczos,
because he had this
eigenvalue idea.
Run that for a while.
Say if you want 10 eigenvalues,
maybe go up to j equal to 20.
So 20 Arnoldi steps,
quite reasonable.
And then look at the 20
by 20 submatrix of H,
so you're not going to
go to the end, to H_n.
You're going to
stop at some point,
and you have this nice matrix.
It'll be tri-diagonal,
symmetric tri-diagonal,
and that's the kind of
matrix we know how to find
the eigenvalues of; so this
is symmetric and tri-diagonal,
and eigenvalues of that class
of matrices are very nice,
and they're very meaningful,
and they're very close to --
in many cases; I won't try
to give a theory here --
in many cases, you get
very good approximations.
The eigenvalues
of this submatrix
are sometimes
called Ritz values,
and they use the eigenvalues
of this submatrix,
and those are often
called Ritz values.
And so the first 10 eigenvalues
of that 20 by 20 matrix,
would be in many, many
problems very fast, very
efficient approximations
to the low eigenvalues
of the big matrix A
that you start with.
OK, the reason is
that eigenvalues --
do you all recognize
that this is the operation, when
I bring Q inverse over here,
that I would call these
matrices similar --
two matrices are similar if
there's a Q that connects them
this way.
And similar matrices
have the same lambdas,
the same eigenvalues.
So the full matrix Q, if we
went all the way to the end,
we could find its eigenvalues,
but the whole point
of all this, of this
month, is algorithms
that you can stop
partway, and you still
have something really good.
OK, so that's -- I think
we can't do everything,
so I won't try to do more with
eigenvalues except to mention
that.
Someday you may want the
eigenvalues of a large matrix,
and I guess ARPACK would
be the Arnoldi pack, that
would be the package to go
to for the Arnoldi iteration,
and then to use for
the eigenvalues.
OK, so that's a side point,
just since linear algebra is --
half of it's linear systems
and half of it's eigenvalue
problems, I didn't think I
could miss the chance to do that
second half, the
eigenvalue part.
OK, now I'm going to
tackle conjugate gradients,
to get the idea.
OK, so the idea,
well, of course, A
is symmetric positive definite.
If it's not, you could
try these formulas,
but you'd be taking
a pretty big chance.
If it is, these are just right.
OK, so what's the
main point about --
here's the rule that
decides what x_k will be.
x_k will be the vector in
the Krylov -- of course,
x_k is in this Krylov space K_k.
So it'll be -- we can
create x_k recursively,
and we should need,
just, if we do it right,
should need just one
multiplication by A at every
step, and then
some inner product.
OK, so now, what do
we know from this?
This vector, since it has
this, it starts with --
it has an x_k that's in
the k-th Krylov subspace,
but now it's multiplied by A, so
that's up to the k plus first.
And b is in K_1, it's in
all the Krylov subspaces,
so this is in -- and therefore
r_k is in -- K_(k+1), right?
This is in the next space
up, because there's a
multiplication by
A. And therefore,
if we choose to determine
it by this rule,
we learn that this
vector -- I mean,
we already know from Arnoldi
that q_(k+1) is orthogonal
to this space.
This is the new k plus first
vector that's in K_(k+1),
so this is just where
this is to be found.
So this vector r_k is found
in the next Krylov subspace;
this one is in the
next Krylov subspace.
They're both orthogonal to all
the previous Krylov subspaces,
so one's a multiple
of the other.
So, that will mean
that automatically,
that the r's have the
same property that Arnoldi
created for the q's:
they're orthogonal.
So the residuals are orthogonal.
So, orthogonal residuals.
Orthogonal residuals, good.
I better say, by the way, when
we do conjugate gradients,
we don't also do Arnoldi, so
Arnoldi's finding these q's;
we're leaving him
behind for a while,
because we're going
to go directly
to the x's and r's here.
So, I won't know the q's but
I know a lot about the q,
so it's natural to write this
simple fact: that each residual
is a multiple of the new
q, and therefore, it's
orthogonal to all the old ones.
And now I want to -- this is the
other property that determines
the new x.
So the new x should be
-- what do I see here,
I see a sort of delta x, the
change in x, the correction --
which is what I want to
compute -- at step k,
that's what I have to find.
And I could look at the
corrections at the old steps,
and notice there's
an A in the middle.
So the corrections
to the x's are
orthogonal in the
A inner products,
and that's where the name
conjugate comes from.
So this is conjugate directions.
Why do I say directions,
and why do I say conjugate?
Conjugate gradients,
even, I could say.
Why did I --
conjugate directions,
I maybe shouldn't
have erased that,
but I'll also say
conjugate gradients.
OK.
So conjugate, all I
mean by conjugate,
is orthogonal in the natural
inner product that goes with
the problem, and
that's given by A.
So the inner product given
by the problem is the inner
product of x and y,
is x transposed A*y.
And that's a good inner product,
and it's the one that comes
with the problem and
so, natural to look
at orthogonality in that
sense, and that's what we have.
So these are orthogonal
in the usual sense,
because they have an A
already built into them,
and these are orthogonal
in the A inner product.
OK.
So I wrote down two
requirements on the new x.
Well, actually you might
say, I wrote down a whole lot
of requirements, because I'm
saying that this should hold
for all the previous i's.
And this should hold for
all the previous i's.
And you see indices
are getting in here,
and I'm asking
for your patience.
What's the point that
I want to make here?
It's this short recurrence
point, this point that we had,
over here, when h was
just tri-diagonal,
so we only needed
-- at the new step,
the only things we had
to find were the --
say at the second step, we just
had to find that h and that h,
because this one was
the same as that.
And then the next one, we --
maybe I didn't say that right.
I guess when we --
let me start again.
At the first step I need
to find two numbers.
Now because H is
symmetric, that's
already the same as that.
So at the next step I
need these two numbers,
and then that number
is already that.
So, two numbers at every
step and big zeros up here.
That's that's the key
point when A is symmetric.
So the same will
be true over here.
We have two numbers, and
they're called alpha and beta,
so they're a little
different numbers,
because we're working with the
x's now and not with the q's,
so you don't see any q's written
down for conjugate gradients.
OK.
All right, let me just look
at the cycle of five steps.
So I have to give it a start,
so I start with d_0 as b and x_0
as 0, and I guess, r_0 which,
of course, is b minus A*x_0.
If that's 0, it's also b.
So those are the starts.
So I'm ready to take a step.
I know the ones
with subscript zero,
and I'm ready for the next step.
I know the ones with
subscript k minus 1,
and I'm ready for this
step, this cycle, k.
So, here's a number.
So I'm coming into this -- well
let me say maybe how I should
say it.
I'm coming into that cycle
with a new d, now what is a d?
It's a search direction.
It's the way I'm going to go.
It's the direction in which
this delta x is going to go.
This delta x is going to be,
probably I'll see it here.
Yeah, there is delta x,
is a multiple of d, right?
If I put this on this
side, that's delta x,
the change in x is
a multiple of d,
so d is the direction
in n-dimensional space
that I'm looking
for the correction,
and alpha is the
number, is how far
I go along d for the best,
for the right, delta x.
So alpha will be determined
by, probably by that.
Probably by that, yeah, it
involves an inner product,
picking off a component.
OK?
So the first step is
to find the number;
the next step is to take
that update, delta x is
the right multiple of
the search direction
that I'm coming in with.
Then correcting r is easy;
I'll come back to that;
if I know the
change in x, I know
the change in r right away.
So that's given me,
I'm now updated.
But now I have to look ahead.
What direction am I
going to travel next?
So the next steps are to find a
number beta and then the search
direction, which isn't r; it's r
again with just one correction.
So it's a beautiful set
of formulas, beautiful.
And I could write -- you know,
because I know x's and r's, I
could write the formulas --
there are different expressions
for the same alpha and beta,
but this is a very satisfactory
one.
OK.
Have a look at that
cycle just to see what
how much work is involved.
How much work is
involved in that cycle?
OK, well, there's
a multiplication
by A, no surprise.
It's that
multiplication by A that
takes us to the
next Krylov space,
takes us to the next update.
So I see a multiplication by
A, and also here, but it's
the same multiplication.
So I see one multiplication
by A. So, easy to list.
So each cycle, there's
one multiplication A
times the search direction, and
because A is a sparse matrix,
the cost there is the number
of non-zeros in the matrix.
OK.
Then, what other computations
do you have to do?
I see an inner product there,
and I'm going to use it again.
I guess, and here it
is at the next step,
so I guess per cycle, I have
to do one inner product of r
with itself, and I have to do
one of these inner products.
So I see two inner products,
and of course, these
are vectors of length n.
so that's 2n multiplications,
2n additions.
OK, this was a multiple of
n, depending how sparse A is,
this is 2n adds and 2n
multiplies for these two
inner products.
OK.
Yeah.
I guess you could
say take them there.
And then what else
do we have to do?
Oh, we have these
updates, so I have
to multiply a vector
by that scalar and add.
And again here, I multiply
that vector by that scalar
and subtract.
Oh, and do I have
to do it again here?
Have I got three?
Somehow, I thought I
might only have two.
Oh, yeah, let me say two
or three vector updates.
People are much better than I
am at spotting the right way
to organize those calculations.
But that's really a very
small price to pay per cycle,
and so if it converges
quickly, as it normally does,
this is going to be
a good algorithm.
Maybe I'll -- maybe having
introduced the question of how
quickly does it converge, I
should maybe say something
about that.
So what's the error,
after k steps?
How is it related to
the error at the start?
So, I have to first say, what
do I mean by this measure
of error, and then I
have to say what's the --
I hope I see a factor, less
than 1, to the k power.
Yeah, so I'm hoping some factor
to the k power will be there,
and I sure hope
it's less than 1.
Let me say what it is.
I think -- so this is maybe
not the very best estimate,
but it shows the main point.
It's the square
root of lambda_max
minus the square
root of lambda_min,
divided by the
square root of that
plus the square root of that.
And maybe there's a
factor 2 somewhere.
So this is one estimate
for the convergence factor,
and you see what it depends
on, I could divide everything
by lambda_min there, so that I
could write that as the square
root of the condition number --
I'll divide by that -- minus 1,
divided by the square root of
the condition number plus 1,
to the k power.
So the condition number has a
part in this error estimate,
and I won't derive that,
even in the notes, I won't.
And other people work out
other estimates for the error,
it's an interesting problem.
And I do have to say
that this norm is
the natural inner
product, e_k squared
is the inner product
of e_k with itself,
but again with A in the middle.
I suppose that a little
part of the message here,
and on that middle board, is
that it's just natural to see
the matrix A playing
a part in the --
it just comes in naturally.
Conjugate gradients
brings it in naturally.
These formulas are just
created so that this will work.
OK.
So I suppose I'm
thinking there's
one word I haven't
really justified,
and that's the word gradient.
Why do we call it
conjugate gradient?
Here I erased --
"conjugate directions"
I was quite happy
with, the directions
or the d's, because this is
the direction in which we moved
from x, so conjugate
directions would be just fine,
and those words come into this
part of numerical mathematics,
but where do gradients come in?
OK.
So, let me say,
gradient of what?
Well, what is --
so first of all,
gradient of what is in these
linear problems where A*x equal
b?
Those come from the
gradient of the energy.
So can I say E of
x for the energy?
As 1/2 x transpose A*x
minus b transpose x?
You might say, where
did that come from?
Normally, we've been talking
about linear systems,
everything's been in terms of
A*x equal b, and now suddenly,
I'm changing to a different
part of mathematics.
I'm looking at minimizing
-- so optimization,
the part that's coming in
April, is minimizing energy,
minimizing function,
and what's the link?
Well, if I minimize that,
the gradient of this is --
how shall I write? grad
E, the gradient of E,
the list of the derivatives
of E with respect to the x_i,
and if we work that out -- well,
why not pretend it's scalar
for the moment, so
these are just numbers.
Then this ordinary derivative
of 1/2 A x squared is A*x,
and the derivative of b*x is
b, and that rule continues
into the vector case.
So what have we got here?
We've computed, we've
introduced the natural energy,
so this is a natural
energy for the problem,
and the reason it's natural
is when we minimize it,
set the derivatives to zero, we
got the equation A*x equal b,
so that would be
zero at a minimum.
This would equal zero at a min,
so what I'm doing right now
is pretty serious.
On the other hand, I'll repeat
it again in April when we do
minimizations,
but this is the --
this quadratic energy
has a linear gradient,
and its minimum is
exactly A*x equal b.
The minimum point
is A*x equal b.
In other words, solving
the linear equation
and minimizing the energy
are one and the same, one
and the same.
And I'm allowed to
use the word min,
because A is positive definite,
so the positive definiteness
of A is what means that
this is really a minimum
and not a maximum
or a saddle point.
OK.
So I was just -- I wanted
just to think about how do you
minimize a function?
I guess any sensible
person, given a function
and looking for the minimum,
would figure out the gradient
and move that way, move,
well, not up the gradient,
move down the gradient, so
I imagine this minimization
problem, I imagine here I'm
in x, this is the x_1, x_2,
the x's; here's the E, E of
x is something like that,
maybe its minimum is there.
This is the graph of E of x, and
I'm trying to find that point,
and I make as first
guess, somewhere there.
Somewhere on that surface.
Maybe, so to help your
eye, this is like a bowl,
and maybe there's
a point, so that's
on the surface of the bowl.
That's x_0, let's say.
I'm trying to get to the bottom
of the bowl, and as I said,
any sensible person
would figure out, well,
what's the steepest way down.
The steepest way down is the
direction of the gradient.
So I could call this gradient
g, if I wanted, and then I
would go in the
direction of minus g,
because I want to
go down and not up.
I mean, we're climbing,
I shouldn't say climbing,
we're descending a mountain,
and trying to get to the --
or descending a valley, sorry.
We're descending into
a valley and trying
to get to the bottom.
And I'm assuming
that this valley
is this nice shape given by
just a second-degree polynomial.
Of course, when we
get to optimization,
this will be the simplest
problem, but not the only one.
Here it's our problem.
Now, of course -- so
what happens if I move
in the direction of -- the
direction water would flow.
If I tip a flask of
water on the ground,
it's going to flow in
the steepest direction,
and that would be the
natural direction to go.
But it's not the best direction.
Maybe the first step is, but
-- so I'm talking now about
conjugate gradient seen
as a minimization problem,
because that's where the
word gradient is justified.
This is the gradient,
and of course, this
is just minus the
residual, so this is
the direction of the residual.
So that's the
question, should I just
go in the direction of
the residual all the time?
At every step -- and this is
what the method of steepest
descent will do, so let
me make the contrast.
Steepest descent
is the first thing
you would think
of, direction is r.
That's the gradient direction,
or the negative gradient
direction.
Follow r until, in that
direction, you've hit bottom.
So you'll go down this,
you see what happens,
you'll be going down one
side, and you'll hit bottom,
and then you will come up
again on a plane that's
cutting through the surface.
But you're not going to
hit that, first shot.
When you start here,
see water would --
the actual steepest direction,
the gradient direction,
changes as the water
flows down to the bottom,
but here we've chosen
a fixed direction;
we're following it as
long as we're going down,
but then it'll start up again.
So we stop there and find
the gradient again there.
Follow that down,
until it goes up again;
follow that down,
until it goes up again,
and the trouble is
convergence isn't great.
The trouble is that
we end up -- even
if we're in
100-dimensional space,
we end up sort of just -- our
repeated gradients are not
really in good, new directions.
We find ourselves doing a lot of
work to make a little progress,
and the reason is that these
r's don't have the property
that you're always looking for
in computations, orthogonality.
Somehow orthogonality tells
you that you're really
getting something new, if it's
orthogonal to all the old ones.
OK.
Now, so this, the
direction r is not great.
The better one is to
have some orthogonality.
Take a direction d that
-- well, here's the point.
This is the right direction;
this is the direction
conjugate gradients choose.
This is where --
so it's a gradient,
but then it removes the
component in the direction we
just took.
That's what that beta will be.
When we compute that beta,
and I'm a little surprised
that it isn't a minus sign.
No, it's OK.
It turns out that
way, let me just
be sure that I wrote
the formula down right,
at least wrote it down
as I have it here, yep.
Again, I'm not
checking the formulas,
but just describing the ideas.
So the idea is that
this formula gives us
a new direction, which has this
property two that we're after.
That the direction, it's
not actually orthogonal,
it's A-orthogonal to
the previous direction.
OK, I'm going to draw one
picture of what -- whoops,
not on that -- of
these directions,
and then that's my best I can
do with conjugate gradients.
I want to try to
draw this search
for the bottom of the valley.
So I'm going to draw
that search by drawing
the level sets of the function.
I'm going to -- yeah, somehow
the contours of my function
are, since my function here is
quadratic, all the contours,
the level sets will be ellipses.
They'll all be, sort of,
like similar ellipses,
and there is the one I want.
That's the bottom of the valley.
So this is the contour
where energy three,
this is the contour energy two,
this is the contour energy one,
and there's the point where
the energy is a minimum.
Well, it might be
negative, whatever,
but it's the smallest.
OK.
So what does -- can I compare
steepest descent with conjugate
gradient?
Let me draw one more contour,
just so I have enough
to make this point.
OK, so steepest descent starts
somewhere, OK, starts there,
let's say.
Suppose that's my
starting point.
Steepest descent goes,
if I draw it right,
it'll go perpendicular, right?
It goes perpendicular
to the level contour.
You carry along until, as long
as the contours are going down,
and then if I continue here,
I'm climbing back up the valley.
So I'll stop here.
Let's suppose that that happened
to be tangent right there, OK.
Now, that was the first
step of steepest descent.
Now I'm at this point,
I look at this contour,
and well, if I've drawn
it reasonably well,
I'm following maybe
perpendicular,
and now again I'm perpendicular,
steepest descent says
go perpendicular to the contour,
until you've got to the bottom
there.
Then down, then up, then do
you see this frustrating crawl
across the valley.
It wouldn't happen if these
contours were circles.
If these contours -- if A
was the identity matrix,
if A was the identity matrix,
these would be perfect circles,
and you'd go to the
center right away.
Well that only says that A*x
equal b is easy to solve when A
is the identity matrix.
So this is steepest descent,
and its rate of convergence
is slow, because the longer
and thinner the valley,
the worse it is here, OK.
What about conjugate gradients?
Well, I'm just going
to draw magic --
I'm going to make
it look like magic.
I'm going to start at the
same place, the first step,
because I'm starting with
zero, the best thing I can do
is follow the
gradients to there,
and now, so that was the
first step, and now what?
Well, the next direction
-- so these are the search
directions.
That's the search direction
d_1, d_2, d_3, d_4.
Here is d_1, and what
does d_2 look like?
May I cheat and go
straight to the center?
It's a little bit of a cheat,
I'll go near the center.
The next direction is
much more like that
and then goes to
the bottom, which
would be somewhere like
there inside that level set,
and then the next direction
would probably be very close.
So this is not 90 degrees unless
you're in the A inner product.
So this is a 90 degree angle
in the A inner product.
And what does the
A inner product do?
In the A inner product,
in which level sets
are circles, or spheres or
whatever, in whatever dimension
we want.
Well, I'm not going
to be, I don't want
to be held to everything here.
If you see this
picture, then we've
not only made headway with
the conjugate gradient
method, which is a big deal
for solving linear systems,
but also we've made headway with
the conjugate gradient method
for minimizing functions.
And if the function
wasn't quadratic,
and our equations
weren't linear,
the conjugate gradient idea
would still be available.
Non-linear conjugate
gradients would somehow
follow the same idea of
A-orthogonal search directions.
So these are not the gradients,
they're the search directions
here.
OK.
That's sort of my speech about
the conjugate gradient method.
Without having checked all
the formulas in the cycle,
we know how much work is
involved, we know what we get,
and we see a bit
of the geometry.
OK.
And we see it as a
linear systems solver
and also as an energy
minimizer, and those
are both important ways to
think of conjugate gradients.
OK.
I'll just take a few final
minutes to say a word about
other -- what if our problem
is not symmetric positive
definite?
What if we have an
un-symmetric problem,
or a symmetric, but not
positive definite problem?
Well, in that case, these
denominators could be zero.
I mean, if we don't know that
A is positive definite, that
could be a zero, it
could be anything,
and that method is broken.
So I want to suggest a safer,
but more expensive method now
for -- so this would be
MINRES, minimum residual.
So the idea is
minimize, choose x_k
to minimize the norm of
r_k, that's the residual.
So minimize the norm
of b minus A*x_k.
So that's my choice of
x_k, and the question is,
how quickly can I do it?
So this is MINRES, OK.
And there are other
related methods,
there's a whole
family of methods.
What do I want to
say about MINRES?
Let me just find MINRES.
Well, yeah.
I guess, for this I
will start with Arnoldi.
So for this different algorithm,
which comes up with a different
x_k, I'm going to
-- and of course,
the x_k is going to be
in the Krylov space K_k,
and I'm going to
use this good basis.
This gives me the
great basis of q's.
So I turn my problem,
I convert the problem.
I convert this minimization --
I look for x as a combination
of the of the q's, right?
Is that how you
see x equals Q*y?
So instead of looking
for the vector x,
I'm looking for
the vector y, which
tells me what combination of
these columns, the q's, x is.
In other words, I'm working
in the q system, the q basis.
So I'm working with y.
So I would, naturally, write
this as a minimum of b minus
A*Q*y_k.
Same problem.
Same problem, I'm
just deciding, OK, I'm
going to find this x as
a combination of the q's,
because those q's
are orthogonal,
and that will make this
calculation a lot nicer.
OK, what's going to happen here?
You know that I'm going to use
the property of the q's that
A*Q is Q*H.
That was the key point
that Arnoldi achieved.
And the net result is
going to be, of course,
I have to do this at level
k, so I'm chopping it off,
and I have to
patiently, and the notes
do that, patiently
see, OK, what's
happening when we chop it
off, chop off these matrices.
We have to watch where
the non-zeros appear.
In the end, I get to a
minimization problem for y,
so we get to a minimum
problem for the matrix
H that leads me to to
the y that I'm after.
So it's a minimum problem
for a piece, sorry,
I should really say H_k, some
piece of it, like this piece.
In fact, exactly that piece.
So if I ask -- all right,
suppose I have a least squares
problem.
This is least squares because
my norm is just the square,
the norm squared.
I'm just working with l^2 norm.
And here's my matrix.
It's 3 by 2, so I'm looking
at least squares problems,
in that -- matrices
of that type,
and they're easy to solve.
The notes will give the
algorithm that solves the least
squares problem.
I guess what I'm interested in
here is just is it expensive
or not?
Well, the least squares
problem will not be expensive;
it's only got one extra
row, compared to the number
of columns, that's not bad.
What's expensive is the fact
that our H is not tri-diagonal
anymore, these are
not zeros anymore.
I have to compute all
these H's, so the hard work
is back in Arnoldi.
So it's Arnoldi
leading to MINRES,
and we have serious
work already in Arnoldi.
We don't have short recurrences,
we've got all these h's.
OK, enough.
Because ARPACK would be a good
code to call to do MINRES.
OK that's my shot
at the key Krylov
algorithms of numerical
linear algebra,
and you see that they're
more subtle than Jacobi.
Jacobi and
Gauss-Seidel were just
straight simple
iterations; these
have recurrence that
produces orthogonality,
and you pay very little,
and you get so much.
OK, so that's Krylov methods,
and that section of notes
is up on the web, and of
course, at some point,
numerical comparisons of how
fast is conjugate gradients,
and is it faster than
direct elimination?
You know, because that's a
big choice you have to make.
Suppose you do have a symmetric
positive definite matrix.
Do you do Gauss elimination with
re-ordering, minimum degree,
or do you make the
completely different choice
of iterative methods
like conjugate gradients?
And that's a decision you
have to make when you're
faced with a large
matrix problem,
and only experiments can compare
two such widely different
directions to take.
So I like to end up by
emphasizing that there's still
a big question.
Do this or do minimum degree?
And only some experiments
will show which is the better.
OK, so that's good for
today, and next time
will be direct
solution, using the FFT.
Good, thanks.